So what would be your perfect weapon of choice for the zombie apocalypse?
Grenade launcher.
Double cannon with a chain attached to it.
Acid sprayer so that you can like melt their brains.
A sentry gun on top.
And I'd get up and just start shooting all the zombies.
A rotor from a helicopter, do some decapitation.
Both have their ups and downs.
I like the idea of the flamethrower just for distance.
The cattle gun's cooler.
I would go with the flamethrower.
Can you put the cattle gun and the flamethrower on the car?
I didn't say you can have all of them.
You get the flames on them, their bodies melting.
I'd probably go with the cattle gun.
I probably would use my signals.
I'd be the last one.
That would probably just tell the zombies where you were going.
Politeness.
I can't even drive as a human being.
But I mean, we're talking about zombie apocalypse.
If you were to stop and, you know, put your window down,...
...the cop that's gonna come over and pull you, he's probably gonna be a zombie.
Yeah, that's not a smart move.
10,000.
If we're going, I might be able to do 30, 40 an hour.
Realistically speaking, I would go with seven.
I would just run over zombies all freaking day.
You're not worried about ammo?
Design and build your Hyundai zombie survival machine now at walkingdeadchopshop.com.
And who would be in charge of cleaning off the horde plow?
He would.
Oh, okay.